[Applause]
the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right hello everyone I'm Ilana
welcome my channel with today I wanted
to play the ghost run a demo which just
today has gone live on Steam this game
sounds so cool looks so cool it's like a
what I'm gonna say is its first person
Gitana zero but it's like I well
probably the closest thing that we'll
get to a modern mirrors edge but very
very combat focused so I thought that I
would give it a shot for myself I'm very
excited beautiful yes great I'm not
doing this by the way game is doing all
of this this is me yes video game is
still adjusting to the software okay I'm
in a prison I can calibrate only your
basic protocols from in here it'll have
to suffice for now
this walls even though I mean it's
really cyberpunk sort of reminds me of
vomit you remembered me don't know that
game similar vibes okay
yeah that's lead to another sector is it
all one hit kills because that route yes
assault role that is a mess oh oh I
should have jumped the deceleration
involved it's great that I should be
that's my batch we sue that turbine
ships - oh that's interesting it looks
like a slingshot I think like yeah it
gives me like a little bit of propulsion
so slowly right now that's cool oh [ __ ]
missed it again
my best okay still longing it's fine I'm
allowed okay yeah and then spacebar and
then spacebar initiate Coulson's reboost
oh yes [ __ ] fall in the era and a
sensory boost and go for the kill okay
aim and release shifted - oh that's cool
again like propulsion but towards the
enemy outside this door zone
okay well KITT I'll find you mmm-hmm
okay shift dodge propel me for 1000 okay
maybe I should go this way
damn alright I'll get it you want to
dull Jim I want to go for it I think I
may be too far away from him in Dodge
thing chump shift this is dope this is
Donald I definitely gonna take me a
little while to get the hang of that and
I imagine it's the same for pretty much
every combat encounter unless there are
a lot of like different enemy types but
very cool very onboard with the white
the shift key like feels like a
slingshot it's sick okay I'll say big
fan is to your advantage
I should have jumped off that slide to
gain speed doing it doing it you soon
where have you gone okay shift
I should have waited it for him yeah I
should have waited so I need it because
otherwise they shoot really quick right
so he'll shift boom and then go for it
dead other guys over bet okay jump
shifts again maybe two nope that's right
there's another one up here you really
got to keep moving huh
shifts don't feel good about that manage
to make it work okay I don't know as I
made that alright let's go let's go I
hate that I keep losing momentum but I'm
sure I'll pick that up as I play more no
one just up here I think hello you see I
feel like I could have doubled back
there but I get the impression this game
just wants me to keep moving so I'm
gonna keep moving oh it's so satisfying
it feels so cool yeah this game is maybe
gonna be like a little bit tough for me
to talk and show you guys at the same
time but um in theory if I am being
quiet it's because I'm showing you guys
how cool the game is which is the point
of this video anyway rather than to be
entertaining or whatever so hopefully uh
haha
I like that doesn't know loading screen
and sure is snappy but the full game
does that oh I don't want to do that
no tenants found outside their homes
will be considered part of the rebel
forces and treated as such gone up here
up here shifts across propel jump shift
across propeller
thanks I go I'm a-goin look again okay
let's go this is very cool very
impressed
really that's a Miss Vicky is afraid
wives got better it got even better
they have grappling hooks where are you
joking
oh this feels so good oh very very quick
though you definitely gotta think faster
it's not difficult
oh my god
this is such a good demo okay oh I
didn't realize our enemies here okay
this is a bit to wrap your head around
grappling hooks combined with jumping
and shifting it's gonna be interesting
this way and then go for it and then aim
and then this way and then go for it
oh it's so good
okay uh I need to get up there you say
alright I think I can do that probably
cool you get up the gods fast will do ah
yeah you're really gonna keep your
momentum up on your ass gets kicked that
much of that gonna shift across whatever
killer thing okay I'm gonna do that I'm
gonna shift another one
oh my god there's two of you that seems
unfair
where'd you go where'd you go where'd
you go [ __ ] no I got it okay I threat
level huh that's gonna be fun for me
can't wait can't wait II who got you out
bud
I got you
free at last
pleasure to meet you face to face that
is now let's take a look inside
I regret maybe doing this feel maybe I
shouldn't have helped you not sure if
that was the right call
very very very cool took about 15
minutes it's true did I think that I
might like play that again now that I
picked it up and and yeah see how fast I
can get that up man very very very good
yeah the demos out right now actually
this video is not in any way sponsored I
am not in any way affiliated with the
team who made this game on any level I
really just thought it was awesome and I
have heard a lot of good things about it
leading up to the demo being released so
I thought that I would share enjoy have
fun
yep y'all doing well like